discussion L
by um great let's talk
welcome hi so uh thank you very much for
the invitation and I want to talk about
some work that I did in the past decade
with these three awesome uh PhD students
of mine at the time so uh the we were
interested in systems of equations of
this form so fixed Point equations
where these things this these uh
functions are
pols and these are equations over some
omega continuous semi ring so thanks to
edish I don't have to tell you very much
about what Omega continuity is just a
reminder it means this relation which is
defined this way the natural order is a
partial order and essentially continuity
means that these chains over this order
have limits infinite chains have limits
the limit is well defined and so and
erish gave you hundreds of examples but
there is one which he didn't mention or
he mentioned only indirectly which is
going to be relevant for this talk so is
the language semi ring where the
elements of the semi ring are languages
uh plus is Union and product is
concatenation okay so excuse me
language generated by regular expression
or something no it's just just languages
so you have you fix an alphabet and the
elements of the semi ring are languages
over the alphabet in principle arbitrary
and then in the rest of this talk I will
just talk about semi- rings but I always
mean this right good uh no so what is
the goal of of This research program if
you want that that we did it was develop
generic solution or approximation
methods right which are valid not just
for one Remi ring but for uh multiple
semi rings and and of course the the the
paradigmatic example of a method which
works for an arbitrary semi- ring is uh
CL Clan iteration so so you have a
system of fix points equations over a
semi- rank then there always exists the
least solution a least fix point with
respect to the Natural order and that
solution is the limit of the sequence z
f of z f of f of zero and so on okay so
this gives you a way an algorithm for
calculating approximating the fixed
point which is to compute these
approximant and stop either when you see
that one approximant is equ to the
previous one then you can stop and you
have the exact result or when you think
that the approximation is good
enough good so I would like to start by
recalling a couple of important facts
about the left linear case so where
where these polinomial are just uh uh uh
linear pols and the coefficients are on
the left so notice that this is
important here because I haven't told
you that the semi- ring is commutative
right most examp will be commutative but
it makes a difference so if you have a a
semi- ring which is not commutative and
you have also coefficients on the right
then Things become much more complicated
but uh for the left linear case so uh
first thing is what happens when you
work over the reals and I am waving my
hands a little bit essentially right
here but basically clar iteration is
going to have linear convergence which I
like to Define I like to Define it in
this way linear convergence what what
means is K iterations will give you
Theta of K uh accurate bits okay so this
means in particular if you double the
number of iterations you will double the
number of uh accurate bits and then
something also important is that for
left linear systems you have gaus
elimination where you define the star of
a semi- rang element like this right is
the and this is defined because we have
an Omega continuous semir Rank and then
ens LMA tells you how to solve solve in
quotes right uh linear equations of this
form tells you that the least solution
of an equation like this is a star
B good and then this immediately gives
you an an algorithm for solving systems
of linear equations assuming that you
know how to compute the star right uh
which is uh you know you pick any
equation you rewrite it like this but
just using distributivity you know and
uh so this is this is going to be a term
which may contain other variables you
know but formally this is going to give
you you replace in all other equations
the variable exi by this and this gives
you in particular when you apply to the
language semi ring this is nothing but a
well-known method of computing a regular
expression for an automat the
finite okay so uh G elimination you know
reduces you should see it like this
reduces solving a
system F lar equations to compute in a
star so if you know how to do this then
you know how to compute the solution
okay now in the over the
reals this is the the the the the case
where everything works wonderfully right
because a star is going to be either
zero if a is equal to zero is going to
be one divided by 1 minus a if a is
between zero and one because a is star
is you know you can is the sum of a
geometric series and it's going to be
Infinity if a is bigger than or equal to
one so you have a very good way of
computing stars but you know uh
something that I like to to to to
mention is what happens in the language
semi ring in the language semi ring we
do not compute a star we just take a
star as the representation of the
language right and the point is that
it's good enough because in the end you
do not want to compute actually all you
can do is to compute some representation
of the solution which is good enough for
your purposes what does it mean good
enough for your purposes usually what
you want to do is query some aspects
about the solution ask questions about
the solution and in the case of the
language semi ring what you can do for
example is once you have the the the the
the regular expression if somebody asks
you whether a word belongs to that
regular expression you can we know how
to do that with the help of finite
automata or you can even answer more
complicated queries okay so actually
it's not even clear what it means to
solve an equation not it's not you don't
always have a canonical representation
which is the one that you obviously
should uh should obtain okay once that
is in place uh we were interested in the
nonlinear case okay and in the nonlinear
case the first thing you observe is that
CL iteration is a miserable uh
technique because it gives you
logarithmic convergence only in the
worst case Okay so the number of
accurate bits is going to be uh to grow
like the logarithm that the Lo like the
logarithm of the number of
iterations and it happens even for this
trivial uh equation you can see that the
least fixed point is one okay but if you
apply 2,000 iterations for example of of
clini iterations you will only have
three accurate bits sorry not bits but
but
digits so um that's a that's a problem
and the second problem is that you know
also you don't have no reduction
for in the linear you have no reduction
in the nonlinear case to Computing a
Stars right or at least no no obvious
one good okay so what can a numerical
mathematician do about this they will
tell you well of course you would never
apply clini iteration here and they
would tell you you would do you would
apply Newton's method okay so uh what is
Newton's method and before let's recall
it but before let's give a graphical
interpretation of Cl iteration so
imagine that we want to solve solve um
the equation this
equation right and now what happens is
that we take here the this is the
straight line Y is equal to X this is
the curve Y is equal to f of x and the
least fix Point well you take the point
where these two lines intersect and uh
this is going to be the fix least fix
point this case equal to work right and
then what graphically what does it mean
to apply CL iteration you start by
Computing F of
zero and then you want to compute F of f
of zero so you reflect this on the a you
have to imagine that this is 45 degrees
which is not but do it in your head
right so then this is going to be F of f
of zero right and then you iterate right
you you compute F of f of zero and so on
and you reach you approximate the fix
point in this way good so what do you do
in Newton's method in Newton's method
for this Newton's method is actually
defined for arbitrary equations of the
form f ofx is equal to zero but of
course X is equal to f of x is a
particular case you just put X on the
other side and when you interpret
Newton's method for this kind of
equation what you are going to obtain is
the following you start by Computing F
of zero but now what you do is you
compute the best linear approximation of
this curve at this point which is just
the derivative okay you compute the
slope
of the of the straight line which is the
derivative and then instead of
intersecting the blue line which with
the black line which is difficult you
intersect the red line with the black
line which is easy because you
intersecting just two straight lines
right and then at that point you compute
the value of the
function and now you do the same you
compute the best linear approximation to
the curve you compute the intersection
and then you compute the value again and
so on and even visually you can see that
this goes faster right the assumptions
on sorry what are the assumptions on for
this differentiable what yeah
differentiable yeah basically
differentiable that's
right
sorry
assumtion uh well not in the particular
case we have now I mean over semi- Rings
everything is monotone right uh in
general it also works for non-monotonic
uh uh uh functions but the problem is
that what you see here in the slide
right the problem is that well Newton's
method is usually very efficient in
practice you see often exponential
convergence that's the reason why for
example when you want to compute a
square root numerically you always use
Newton's method because it's going to
have this Behavior it's going the number
of accurate B is going to double with
each iteration right but the problem is
in general you you are not applying it
only to monotone function functions and
so on in general is not robust it may
not converge it may converge only
locally in some neighborhood of of the
leak fix point which you have to guess
you have to guess a point which is close
enough to the leak fix points that you
converge there or is going to converge
various slowly okay so uh uh the problem
is then that when we started or if you
want when we started this this program
what we had is this frustrating mismatch
right Clan iteration is very Rob fast
you can apply it to every semi- rink but
uh is going to converge slowly in
particular over the reals right and
Newton's method May converge very fast
but it's not robust and it can only be
applied to the reals it wasn't clear how
do you apply it to an arbitrary sing
okay good so these are the two main
results of this program first Newton's
method can be generalized to arbitrary
semi rings and for this particular case
it becomes just a robust as cleenish
method so it's always going to converge
and uh we will not have this these
problems with local convergence there is
always Global convergence convergence
starting from zero and so on okay and
the second result is that over the reals
right Newton's method converges at least
linearly and often exponentially so it's
at least as good as
as PL iteration in the linear case but
you know but it converges exponentially
often over the real semi ring and never
worse than linearly and I must say this
was done there we did some work on this
we had some contribution there but this
is mostly work done by Sami Stewart and
janak is in a series in a series of
papers good so uh how do you and I'm
going to here I'm going to talk mostly
about this U or actually almost only
about this good so how do you generalize
Newton's method okay so we are going to
use this derivation tree analysis idea
that Matias already introduced yesterday
so uh and the first idea is that you
know trivially an equation let's think
of one single equation but this
generalizes without any problem to a
system of equations right an equation
over a semi- ring induces a context free
grammar and you know the context free
grammar induced by this equation is just
this here okay so you consider these uh
things here these numbers as
elements of the semi ring asct elements
of the sem pols now assuming a pol now
yes yeah yeah so I say yeah so uh uh
yeah I mean over semi- Rings everything
is a polinomial right how do you define
other things and you need you need
additional structure you in order to
introduce something different okay and
so this will be the context free grammar
Associated to this equation yeah and if
you have a system of equations then you
Associated context gramar with
multiple yeah in the next slides we are
going to consider this running example
because it's it already contains all the
important elements so a b and c think of
them as semi- ring elements arbitraries
so over some semi- ring and then we have
this equation and this is the associated
context okay okay so now uh given a
grammar uh a grammar has in a grammar
you can have derivation trees right you
can derive words by applying the
Productions of the grammar so what we do
is we assign to a derivation three the
geld of the tree and the yield is
defined as the order because it the semi
ring could be non non-commutative right
order product of the leaves of the tree
right so for example the the the geld of
this tree is C the G of this derivation
tree of the grammar is a * C * C and
here you have a * C * B * C and then the
G yeld of a set of trees is the sum in
the semi ring of the gelds of all trees
right so the geld of this set of three
trees is going to be this and
R good so now you have this fundamental
proposition which is not really
difficult to prove so let D be the set
of all derivations trees of G then
theide is the least fixed point is the
geld of the complete set of derivation
trees okay so given an equation you have
a Leist fix point but you can also go
from the equation to the grammar from
the grammar you can go to the set of
derivation trees and you go to the Gil
and then these two things
are
okay good so now then something that you
can start thinking about is well when I
consider an approximation method I can
try to look at this method as capturing
the geld of more and more
trees okay and the question is which are
the trees that the approximation me
measure method is
capturing so in the case of clean
approximation is again also very easy to
show that it amounts to capturing trees
according to actually height I should
put height here so according to height
okay so is that the first uh Clin
Proxima will be the Jil of all trees of
height one and then height two and then
height three at at I should say at most
one at most two at most three and so on
right there was a question yeah so the
Yi of a set is the sum of the Yi yeah
exactly so you use product to compute
the yield of a tree and you use sum to
compute the yield of a set yeah sorry if
I miss this but this is we are in the UN
Cas uh no no uh it's going to be okay so
if you want that it will be a bit more
complicated imagine that you have
multiple equations here then what you
will do is in order to obtain the
component of the fixed point or the
compon or the the the component of the
approximation corresponding to the
variable x i you will consider only the
trees with x i at the
root okay so when you consider the
derivation trees if I don't tell you
which is the Axiom of the grammar these
grammars do not have an axiom right
actually what you have is for each
variable its own set of
derivations variable variable okay other
questions no good okay so this is
uh characterization of the clini
proximum and now the question is what is
the characterization of the Newton
approximants and this is our fundamental
theorem our fundamental theorem is the I
Newton approximant is the G of all
derivation trees of a staler number at
most I so instead of capturing trees by
height you capture trees by a ster
number and probably you are all asking
yourself what the hell is the ster
number of a tree right good um ster is
Arthur n strer who in 1952 published
this paper and he wasn't a computer
scientist he wasn't a mathematician he
was a geographer of a geologist and the
definition of the St number is in this
paper right very fitting for our worship
so the problem that estalar had was you
know in the early 50s you started to
have
aerial pictures of of of of uh things
like this like a system of rivers and
now the question you have is what if I
give you a picture like this and I ask
you which is the main
river well H now is here is very easy
because I have drawn it thicker for you
right but imagine that all these
segments would be equally thick then you
have to decide in some way and which is
the algorithmic way in which you can
decide which is the main river so estler
proposed made a
proposal and what he said is well let's
assign to each segment in this picture a
number and the idea is the
fingertip segments so you know the ones
where you have you know a source you
give them you assign them number one
okay and then the rule is the following
when two
streams first order streams you know uh
join then the resulting stream is going
to have strer number two okay and then
if two streams of order two join then
the resulting stream will have a Str
number three and so on okay so for
example here uh you have uh one stream
of order two and another stream of order
two and then the resulting stream is of
order three is black and here two black
streams get into a green stream of order
four yeah it's Max of the two plus one
uh wait a second because they uh Max of
the two plus one uh no because here what
you have is a if you have you have here
a stream of order three which joins a
street or is joined by a stream of order
two and then the result is order three
you do not change the order okay so yeah
so for identifying like continuous or
continuous seg segments of streams like
we have these dark segs are all threes
establishing what is considered a three
by looking at where you have the same
ster numbers next to each other like how
do you decide that say the stream coming
off of those twos that you identified
before is still the same three segment
the whole way so you mean how I do I
identify that this one this segment is
the same as this have the same color as
this one or I don't know yeah well you
know in this a a segment here is color
black if it has uh a stroller number
three right so here this segment has a
stroller number three this segment has a
stroller number two right and then this
segment has a Str number three
okay so the colors are just remember the
sorry the colors just tell you which are
the I have colored the segments
according to the rester
number now if you want to and what the
St was saying is then well if you want
to know which is the main stream then
start at
four and then decrease only when you
don't have any choice right so here you
go here and then here you have to
decrease well when you have to decrease
because two two exams of of uh strer
number three join then you can take any
of the two and he had he gave additional
instructions on how to um uh choose
which one but we don't care about those
because they are not topological they
are metric right but here at this point
you you don't have to decrease you could
take if if you take this one you
decrease but you don't have to so then
you continue with three okay and you
continue with three until you have no
choice which happens here right and then
that gives you one possible mainstream
yeah so that we could also go left and
then here we could also have gone left
yeah okay good uh yeah by the way this
is a real German river the El
River okay so that mathematically this
is the definition we prefer to start
counting at zero but the idea is that
what is the ster number of a tree well
you define it inductively the ster
number of a three with just one note is
zero okay and now what happens how do
you decide the staler number of a node
in the tree well you look at this uh
children and you look at the aser number
of the children and you take the maximum
of those if you see the maximum here
among the children exactly once right
then you you keep the ster number if you
see the maximum at least twice then you
increase by
one okay so that's the that's the
inductive
definition uh so another way of looking
at it is a tree has a ster number K
bigger than zero if it consists of a
spine right which such that all the
subtrees which do not belong to the
spine have a ster number at most K minus
one and the spine ends at some point
where at least two children have a a
strer number exactly K minus
one
characterizations uh sorry this is a
mistake right characterizations for
example the St number of a tree is the
height of the the largest minor that is
a full binary tree okay that you can
embed in the in the tree or for example
if you like a more operational view
imagine that you have an arithmetic
expression like this and you have to
evaluate it right the ster number is the
minimal the minimal number of registers
that you need in order to evaluate it
okay because depending the number of
registers depends on the order evalu of
evaluation if you take the optimal order
then that's the
strer okay
good so now that we have this theorem
which I'm not going to prove it's a bit
more complicated right then how can we
use it to
compute so uh the idea is let's let's
keep our let's take our running example
right and the idea is simple so let's or
the first idea is simple let's try to
unfold this grammar g into grammars g0
G1 G2 and so on so that the derivation
trees of the K grammar contains only the
Tre of G of a stroller number at
MOS
okay how to do that is not very
complicated so uh here you have um how
to do it for this particular example so
how do you compute GC so ezo is should
have is a grammar which should produce
only the the Trees of ofer number zero
okay and then well the only one that you
have there is
C more generally in order to do it
systematically well it's say let's
introduce these two variables
right XK but with the um how do you call
this with a bracket right I guess so
yeah this generates the Trees of a ster
number exactly K or is going we are
going to design the grammar in such a
way right and this one with a square
parenthesis they generate the Trees of a
ster number less than or equal to K and
the only thing which is important here
don't don't read all this mambo jumbo
is this equation or this this set of
Productions because this is going this
corresponds exactly to the um inductive
definition of a staler number what this
is telling you is the
following I want this should this this
should produce trees of Aer number
exactly K right so then how can
a tree a tree of a ster number exactly K
look like well it could start with this
production right and then what happens
if it starts with that production the
tree looks like
this but then there are three
possibilities one possibility is these
two sub trees both of them have a ster
number exactly K minus one because then
you have to go one up this corresponds
to this term
okay or this one generates a a three of
a ster number exactly K and this one
generates a tree of a star number
smaller than k at most K minus one this
corresponds to this
term okay you need also the other term
because it could be the other way around
and what and that accounts for what can
happen with this uh with this production
now what can happen with this production
then the tree is going to look like
this okay and now here you must have a
tree of a ster number exactly K
otherwise you don't get the ster number
a three of a ster number a here okay so
that's why you have this
two good so it's very easy then to
produce to unfold the grammar in this
way inductively right and The crucial
observation uh well and then of sorry
since you have this now how do you can
how can you generate the semi- rink
values or the yields you know of uh the
Trees of a ster number equal to K or
less than or equal to K you just
substitute here uh the U the the bars in
the in the grammar by plus right and and
the concatenation by
product good now the problem is do you
solve these equations right iteratively
well the important observation is that
this equation which is the crucial one
right this equation is always linear
in in the
variable so what happens then is that
Newton's method what Newton's method is
telling you is that you can approximate
the solution of nonlinear
equations assuming that you can solve or
at least approximate linear equations so
so it does not do the whole thing for
you you still have to come up with a way
of solving linear equations right and
then Newton's method will tell you how
to approximate General equations and now
you can see also the correspondence to
the geometric intuition remember what we
were doing we were replacing the
nonlinear equation by the best
approximation that was the derivative
right and then we were saying okay
instead of computing the intersection of
the curve with the line with the
straight line we compute the
intersection of the two lines we assume
that we know how to compute the
intersection of the two lines if we know
how to do that we can then solve the
general
good so for example in uh take now our
example uh and imagine that or let's
consider this equation and now imagine
that the semi ring is
commutative if the semi ring is
commutative then you can reverse the
order here and then with you have is
that x with bracket K is equal to this
linear equation okay so it is it is
notice that we can we assume now that we
have recursively computed this term and
this
term and now what we have is a linear
equation on XK and then you can apply
ens LMA okay so then in this way you
obtain the
uh the approxim I mean the solution for
excape here so in particular if you are
over the language semi- ring the what
you are doing is approximating a context
free Language by regular
languages question yeah so you calculate
x uh angle brackets K minus one by the
from the previous iteration right so how
do you calculate square bracket yeah
well square brackets yeah that's a good
question and I should have said it it's
very simple so square brackets means uh
trees the geld of trees of star number
at most K so then these are the
sorry Square means at most and bracket
and angle brackets means exactly I see
okay so this is then uh this right just
accumulate okay just
accumulate other questions
no so in particular now you know what it
means to approximate context free
language using Newton's method I miss
something very basic at the start what
do you mean by approximating the
language how do you define the
approximation of the language you'll get
a language and compare to the context
fre language the two are close no you
just are Computing is larger and larger
subsets of the language and you know
that in the limit you will have all the
words in the language so there will for
every word in the language which there
is going to be an approximation which
contains it but is there a nonsense
similar to the bits of accuracy that we
had in of I mean you have to you would
have to Define that right so for example
you can start
defining in general no right because you
don't have a metric but what you can do
for example is imagine that you have a
probabilistic context fre
grammar in fact this gives you a method
by which I mean you can compute actually
using this technique you can compute the
new approximant is going to give you a
regular language together with the
probability of that language right so
you know that the in general the
probability of generating a word is
going to be one and then you can say
well you know if you take the fourth
Newton approximation you have this
regular language and you know that the
probability of generating one word in
this language is
97% okay so then you can say oh this is
good enough for me I don't care about
the rest I will take this as a good
approximation of the the convergence
here is exponential the convergence is
going to be at least linear in the
number of
iterations and uh very often is going to
be
exponential so actually what this is
telling you is that if you take you give
me any any uh probabilistic context free
grammar and essentially it is I can tell
you it will be very with the probability
of generating something of highest strer
number is very
low probability of generating a word
such that the you can only generate it
with Tre of a strer number of this Ester
number is very low because you know a
word could have different derivation tws
right good so now um I don't have much
time right I I how much time you have 12
minutes sorry 12 minutes 12 oh
wow then then I can tell you a little
bit that's that's great 12 minutes is
great I was thinking on four or
something okay because then the rest of
the stuff is going to be well a couple
of applications uh in quotes
applications right depending on what
your your your take on on how apply this
is so uh the first thing is that well
you can use this to prove that Newton's
method terminates for uh in particular
this class of semi Rings Newton's method
terminates over item ENT and commutative
sems what this means is that there is a
fixed number of iterations such that
after that number of iterations you know
that you already have reached the fix
Point okay and which is the class of
semi- rings well uh well as you see
first if if you have n polinomial
equations then you are going to finish
after n plus1 iterations and which is
the class of semi- rings these are
either potent and commutative semi Rings
right so this means plus is ID potent
and product is is
commutative now uh how do you interpret
this from the point of view of the
derivation trees remember the geld of a
tree is the product of the leaves and
the jeld of a set of trees is the sum
okay of the of the gelds of the trees so
plus being either potent means that you
don't care about how many copies you
have of a tree or of a word okay you
only worry about the possible GS and
know and not about their
Multiplicity okay and uh commutative
means that you don't care about the
order in the leaves right you only care
about how many times you have each
letter in the
geld good so then what you can do in
order to prove this result all you have
to do is this prove that for every
derivation Tre yeah what what is ID
potent I'm sorry Iden potent means that
a plus a is a right oh
okay okay good so now all you have to
prove is that for every derivation tree
in the grammar there is going to be a
derivation tree which produces not
necessarily the same word but a
commutative sorry a a permutation of
that word right and with a small staler
number and you can prove that okay you
can prove that for every word there is
always a a strer a tree of a staler
number at most n plus one which is going
to generate not necessarily the same
word but a um permutation of that word
yeah can you comment on the connection
to
par C generalization yes I
can thank you for the yes and in fact a
consequence of this is a constructive uh
um a constructive proof of paric theorem
so paric theorem tells you for every
context free language there is a regular
language with the same commutative image
okay and um uh using this technique we
can you can derive a uh a an algorithm
that generates actually a uh
a an automaton for the for this regular
yeah one says about what happens if you
don't have the item po
uh well I can say that things get more
complicated but what do you what would
you expect or what I mean does it
converge we converge more slowly does it
is it unknown does it possibly not
converge there are we so okay so first
of all the problem is one there is one
fundamental problem what does it mean to
converge fast in an arbitrary semi- ring
um you don't have
a there is not no generic way of
defining that right you can only Define
that when you have some kind of metric
that tells you how far are you from some
point right yeah well then for example
in the case that you are mentioning
there are things that you can do by
saying that okay if you compute up to
this number if you compute this this
Newton approximate then if you have
capture this tree then you have capture
also at least as many copies of the tree
okay there are results about like those
the question is whether they are good
enough for you to do something or not
right that depends on you yeah was there
any attempt to to substitute for this
some kind of kosi condition that the so
you do have natural order so so if uh n
a n + one minus a minus one is in some
sense bigger sorry smaller than a minus
one yeah but what does that mean right
does it mean you if you count the if you
count the numbers of words probably for
example it can be the case that each
approximant gives you infinitely many
words each of them could give you
infinitely many new words we do have
examples of semi rings in which there
can be S to checks okay for example the
tropical or the you know where where
those values have an order even the
natural orderorder has has
a good interpretation there that
connects to our intuition right so all I
can say is we have tried what I said
before trying to see okay if you if you
have generated some tree how many copies
of the tree have you generated try to
give lower bounds no we haven't look at
kosi uh conditions that looks
interesting if you have any because you
seem to have an intuition of semi Rings
where that would make sense and then
that would be great that would be
fantastic right because then that gives
you a
to of pols there I don't know what sense
do they make but yes no but what I mean
pols in in a semi ring everything is a
polinomial right so you only have plus
and
times natur Pol okay good yeah that that
uh that could be
interesting one more question yeah just
going back to that ID so if I just have
something like a + a + n * equal
to a
then that convergence extends to
that so you said A Plus AAL a but there
might be a plus a plus after n iteration
it goes back to a yeah sure a a so n
times a is going to be a yeah that case
that
theorem gives you some bound I mean
previous theorem
said well this is this is yeah the
previous theorem is telling you that you
are done after n plus1 iterations you
don't have to continue you have already
reached the exact
solution right but that's for the ident
poent but this is this uh it is well it
is you need both ident poent and
commutative right I have this means a
plus a a yeah but if I have a plus a
plus up to n and then it becomes a ah
okay sorry sorry that's what you mean
you mean replacing ID poent by a plus a
may be different from a but a ah right
right right right yes uh yeah that works
too no I don't I don't remember now you
have to change this yes but I I have I
must say I have to check it yeah sorry
now I understand what you mean I'm sorry
yeah okay good I was uh yeah okay uh
then uh yeah so paric theorem so how do
you so the idea is that now you know
that the regular language which is going
to have the same commutative image is
going to be the N plus one approximation
okay all the approximations are regular
languages and the moment you compute the
M plus one then you know that you
already have uh something which is whose
commutative image is the same as the
image of and then don't you're not going
to understand this but uh doesn't matter
I mean uh so if you take this context
free grammar our algorithm will
construct you this automat right so I'm
not going to tell you how but this is a
constructive version
of Parish paric theorem tells you this
this regular language exists and of
course the proof gives you a
construction but it's not very nice I
must say I think this is I think this is
much
nice good um and then I would like to
finish how how much time do I have now
then two minutes then I'm going to skip
this if anybody is interested in how to
reduce or or how to design a
recommendation system uh um which is
able to you know capture things like uh
uh
membership membership in groups by so
where essentially you can Define groups
recursively where you can do things like
this person recommends this group with
this weight where you can Define the
groups also recursively for example I
can say I can Define the recursively the
set of my friends by saying these
persons are my friends and then there is
a general rule that the friends of my
friends are my friends
okay and maybe even with a dumping
Factor where you say well these persons
are my friends the friends of my friends
are also my friends but not so much my
friends as my friends and so on all that
can be in this can be done with this uh
systems of polinomial equations and you
can use Newton's method in order to
compute how with how much weight are we
all for example as a community
recommending a particular person I may
be recommending a person because I know
him somebody else in direct because he's
a coauthor of a friend and so on right
good so but I don't have time for that
so uh ask me about it if you are
interested and then let me go through
this and let me go through thank
you let's take one or two questions and
the main many questions we have we keep
needing for the interactive
discussion so so your about convergence
has to do with a number of durations of
but each iteration requires to Sol the
linear system
which you can think about also you need
to number of iterations to compute the
line system so can you say something
about the total number of
iterations in that
s uh well okay example yeah no let's
let's see I mean so what you are saying
is completely right so you may not have
a way I mean if you can if you have a
way or if you are happy with or if you
have some way of computing a stars that
you are happy with right or if you are
happy with leaving the stars as they are
as it would happen with regular
languages right then you can you can
solve the linear equations
exactly okay so if you cannot then you
can always apply clean iteration I mean
Newton's iteration does not help you at
all for linear equations then you will
have to do clar iteration and then
indeed well all you know is that over
the real
right clini iteration is going to
converge linearly I mean there are some
Corner cases but essentially linearly
right so you can then decide how many
iterations you want to do of a clini the
problem is you know over the reals you
can solve linear linear equations
exactly right so again you have to go to
you have to tell me which is your semi-
ring right once you or or some idea
about your semi rink and then one can
start thinking about how many iterations
of Clinic with
uh would be good to do so so that you
can combine them with Newton because
Newton's method works well also if you
have only an approximation of the linear
equation right you can apply them you
can take that instead of the real
solution of the exact solution and apply
Newton's method you can use that to
accelerate or to obtain better
results thank you for this great talk do
you get any leverage if your semi ring
is a semi
field because I'm thinking you have a
new example would be the rational
functions in one variable that's a semi
field and that would somehow help you
thinking about the the difference that
allows you toine the derivative and so
on great question I don't know
yes okay let's take a 15 minute break
before we have two more talks and
then
that's